suicide offered as a treatment for
mental illness now it used to be that
you would go to a therapist to help you
not kill yourself in Canada very soon it
may work the other way and when you
consider that 20 of adults supposedly
have a mental illness according to the
people who are in charge of determining
these things anyway you begin to see how
Bleak this picture really is if mental
illness is a legitimate reason to
execute somebody then pretty soon we're
all going to be eligible now it's been
easy for many people in this country to
ignore made because for the most part
it's happening in Canada but euthanasia
is growing in popularity here too in
fact just this month the U.S got its
very first suicide tourism State the
Republican governor of Vermont signed a
bill allowing euthanasia customers to
come from anywhere in the country to be
killed they'll start putting that in
their tourism ads hey you want to kill
yourself come to Vermont and do it